one disaster would wipe us out whether
nuclear or chemical or whatever I mean
we are so close to the train tracks
train tracks running right through the
valley and into the middle of Las Vegas
but what are they carrying it's a
question our eight news now
investigators have been asking for
months after this train carrying
hazardous materials derailed in Ohio 50
cars going off to tracks right near the
Ohio Pennsylvania line sending highly
flammable chemicals into the environment
so what if that happened here and why
can't anyone say what's on these trains
here's 8 news now investigators to the
charts
this map shows all of the Rail lines
across Nevada some 1200 miles of track
and you can see right there in the
southern part of the network goes right
through the middle of Las Vegas neither
the Federal Railroad Administration nor
any government agency can tell us the
specific hazardous materials the trains
on these lines are carrying what would a
trained derailment mean for Las Vegas
within 100 yards of this building if
that stuff that happened there was a
train derailment downtown Las Vegas
would have been basically off limits
it's something commissioner tick
sagerbloom doesn't want to see a trained
derailment in the Las Vegas Valley on
the scale of East Palestine Ohio the
fiery crash last February releasing
toxic chemicals forcing nearly 2 000 to
leave their homes you can imagine what's
what's in those tankers tankers
plastered with warnings running just
feet from segerbloom's office at the
Clark County Government Center did you
wonder what these trains were carrying
in your own District I guess in a sense
Wonder but other hand probably assumed
the worst segerbloom says he has to
assume the worst because the exact
contents on these massive chains of
cargo are secret well we know what's on
some trains like this one that derailed
earlier this year near Baker California
carrying iron ore the multi-mile long
links are transporting many different
materials the nearly two mile long train
in East Palestine had 20 different
combustible and flammable liquids and
gases including something called Vinyl
chloride the CDC calls it colorless
highly flammable and potentially
explosive that's one of the problems
when you have this top secret stuff and
everybody's operating under security and
and that a lot of times they think they
don't have to tell us and and if we
don't discover it then we never know
Diego's now investigators asked several
local state and federal agencies one
simple question what's on the trains a
spokesperson for the city of Las Vegas
said quote what the trains are carrying
is not shared with local jurisdictions
both he and Clark County told us to ask
the Railroad Union Pacific for details
the company says it's required by
federal law to quote transport chemicals
and other hazardous Commodities that
Americans use daily including fertilizer
ethanol crude oil in chlorine no public
entity nor the railroad would say
exactly what is on these cars beyond
that the American Association of
railroads a trade group four Freight
Carriers notes there are thousands of
distinct products not all hazardous on
our nation's tracks but their fact sheet
for Nevada about what's on the trains is
redacted to quote preserve
confidentiality should the public know
what's on these trains
they should I'm not sure about each
train
um but but I think it's pretty clear
that that
the more knowledge you have the better
Clark County Las Vegas and Henderson all
have specific plans in place and
specialized teams to respond if there
were a Hazmat rail emergency but the
County's emergency plans dated January
2022 use data as old as 2005 with no
specifics on materials and a phone
number to call for a railroad
representative about specific shipments
the 8 News investigators found over the
past 10 years 43 trains have derailed in
Nevada just one with what the Federal
Railroad Administration calls a Hazmat
release but the report for that
derailment only says it involved a quote
alcohol of unknown amounts unless we
know specifically what we're protecting
against we're probably are under
protected
representatives from Union Pacific say
their trains are safe and there are
measures ensuring safety on the tracks
Democrats in Carson City are looking to
beef up that security by ensuring
detector systems they're meant to alert
the often just two-person crew that a
train could derail the original Bill
attempted to actually restrict the
length of some of these trains some of
the miles long to about just a mile but
that part of the bill was gutted Union
Pacific noting it's unclear what power
any state has over Interstate Commerce
I'm David charns 8 News Now